hello everyone and welcome to the lobby
GameSpot's weekly hangout here at 2 p.m.
Pacific we kind of thought Daniel Dwyer
might still be in the intro video it's a
bittersweet episode it is our first
without the great Daniel Dwyer he's gone
to do new and exciting things and we
wish him the best but the show must go
on
so I'm Mike McCarty I'm your host now
and I'm here as often is the case and
will often be the case as Peter Brown I
am still here yeah and your beard is
much less bushy than I'm used to yeah it
was pretty big he was getting it was
getting up there but I got a lot of hair
in my head his weigh me down it's more
than me and Rob Henry hey what's going
on I can't really grow a beard I feel
like I comment on Petes too much just
beard Envy I love it
we have kind of a long episode today
there's a bunch of smaller segments
we're gonna get through but yeah so
stick around I guess you'll know when it
ends but uh anyway we're gonna start
with Bioshock remaster which is out this
week I guess there's two caves calling
it a Bioshock celebration or something
what anniversary is it an anniversary
10th yes 2006 bioshock sure yeah maybe
that was the occasion but it's on ps4
Xbox one
I guess we're talking about like
bioshock's legacy kind of because people
have not talked about Bioshock enough at
this point and taking you guys are both
fans of the series yes
political commentary environmental
storytelling and ran and ran and ran and
ran yeah it's uh I think the general
consensus I don't know still like maybe
you guys would disagree I still like the
first the most out of all three the
first hit me the hardest yeah and I
actually was late to the game I mean I
played all three but having been so when
but we'll about when BioShock Infinite
was like being teased and like honest
way to become least I was like oh I
gotta go back and play so I played him
all in a row and man that first one like
had such great twists in the story just
that world was so engrossing yeah I mean
that that's it was definitely my
favorite games all the way through that
game to like the ride was like for real
like I don't know this you know so many
movies or games and anything you didn't
agree on is like oh there's a drop here
I didn't feel that way at all at that
game like all the way through yeah it
was like a really impressive
a collection of set pieces put
underwater which was kind of novel at
the time like we hadn't seen a lot of
that but then you coupled it with this
whole Big Daddy little sister thing for
me what that was the iconic experience
of the original game that just still
sticks with me and I kind of and then I
guess they didn't wear it out but they
sort of it ran its course so I
understand why it didn't continue and
into infinite but yeah that's really
what stood out for me that was like a
pretty and the moral choice was so real
right and yeah yeah you had the twist
would you kindly twist which I guess I
won't spoil if you don't know it by now
but it doesn't really it's you know
marked for kind of being the one that
you know asked like actually looks at
like what it means to play games so if
she want to get really deep into it but
still like I played it I think two years
ago again and I haven't played the
remastered version on ps4 or anything
but it still holds up really well and
how it feels like it's it's still a
little jarring because there's not any
auto aim which we're so or maybe there
is like that miniscule want to help you
but it's very very kind of unforgiving
if you're not accurate obviously you can
use plasmids and whatnot in addition to
just conventional like yeah nineteen
forty's Fifty's weapons but it held up
like really well from what I played and
obviously to you return to rapture to is
the one that I'd like not to be
contrarian but I actually think I like
it more than a lot of people you
contrarian pretty yeah way different
shrugging off the insult anyway yeah it
was way different right I mean I had
that horror feel feel to it where you
know already there's like chaotic
splicers right as what they call them
all around the world and then you know
you have this it's a it's big sister
right the the there's one that stalks
you yeah I'm that every aspect of wool
there that character was was terrifying
the noise you knew when it was about to
come after you
it would kick your ass you felt like you
were constantly on like an East like
throughout that game yeah the really
cool thing and kind of disappointing
obviously the big sister shows up at set
moments throughout Bioshock to the
original plan was to under 2k Marin was
to have heard this like persistent
threat that wasn't scripted kind of like
if you played a resonable 3 nemesis the
Nemesis randomly will bust through walls
and doors
yeah I mean that makes that game a
novelty but I almost wish they hadn't
liked shirk that and just kept that if
they made like to the one where she's
constantly chasing you you're just like
almost always worried about your
well-being even more than you already
were I thought that would've been a cool
design concede that sounds pretty cool
thinking of it in the same terms as
Resident Evil 3 because the Nemesis was
definitely a game changer in that regard
for that series yeah yeah and like
Minerva's dens probably one of my
favorite DLCs in general the team who
like two of the members on fulbright
company who did gone home they're
working on tacoma they did Minerva's
down Steve Gaynor was a lead designer
it's well worth playing just I Bioshock
2 is well worth playing just to play
Minerva's Den but in terms of gameplay
Bioshock 2 was different in the way you
could you could do like the Skyrim a
power in one hand a weapon in the other
as the big-daddy which was really fun I
think it's kind of underrated in terms
of gameplay and I thought it actually
flows really well from like one combat
situation situation to another and how
you combine weapons and how you use the
powers to supplement them I think that's
like one thing the game doesn't always
get talked about I think it's just
overshadowed by the first Bioshock
I didn't play Bioshock 2 but I know the
conversation around it is sort of like
yeah it's the lesser of those first two
games but what was the how did it fall
short in a lot of people's eyes I hate I
think it was just the this story was
almost like felt like it was lingering
in rapture too long and they didn't
really make use of the fact that it was
cool that you were a Big Daddy because
the first game you Don the Big Daddy
armor later on right and it slows you
down and those kind of cumbersome from
what I remember a moment or two right it
was it was like a chapter if that but
Bioshock 2 I feel like it's very fun
game I just don't think it changed
things up enough to warrant this hanging
around and rapture giving you a glimpse
at like this world that you know rapture
the first one was interesting because
you're figuring out why it crumbled and
like you're kind of seeing it happen in
the process as well Bioshock 2 it had
already done it was just just decrepit
underwater city and it wasn't exactly
didn't really seem to be going anywhere
the whole time although it is really fun
for a moment a moment and then obviously
2013 BioShock Infinite rolls around and
it's totally different here in Columbia
the flying said you're in the sky
you're in the sky yeah you're you go
from what it was the Gungan City called
and Phantom Menace
don't
waiting for someone through the
comparison I'd throw it yeah we like
their rebreathers if they wear yes I I
was a huge fan of that game despite the
Phantom Menace no it's a game not sure
there was a game whatever um yeah I
actually really like that game
I mean visually I actually like enjoyed
that game a lot and I felt it kind of
got overshadowed with like you know the
the themes of like racism and all that
stuff
like I mean that people really didn't
like that I find it really interesting
all the way through and I thought the
twist at the end was was freaking crazy
that was a game we're like I personally
wouldn't put so much time I think also
because I played like eating like two
sittings like I just went nuts on that
so yeah yeah it was like I just went
nuts I had really well I was laid off at
when I was my last job and I had nothing
to do on memories my job let's escape
and so yeah it was like two three
settings and man like that twist like
had me thinking for a couple days it was
one of those moments you know there's
movies and games your life where you
just like can't stop thinking about it
and I even was so frustrated with
attending that I immediately it fresh me
in a good way I was just like a really
like curve ball for me oh so fresh good
was like I'm gonna see it I want to play
it again I immediately started playing
again realize I probably shouldn't
I should go eat or something like that
money all those motifs and foreshadowing
things from that from that game all the
way through you know in the first few
seconds they were doing stuff like that
and I thought that was just really great
but visually two updates it's stunning
game yeah especially for its time
I'm assuming you played it as well Peter
I did I never ended up finishing it but
I'd but I definitely really liked what
was there the it was impressive to me
how they could sort of make the game
feel like Bioshock but have it in such a
different setting with all of that
mobility stuff thrown on top I thought
that right really rad and I like those
sort of mechanics and games and it just
married really well with bioshock's
style of shooting yeah so yeah I can't
remember why I didn't finish it I got
pretty far into it though and I
definitely liked it yeah I don't like
the statute of limitations on spoilers
up yet or no like
probably not I don't want it it is a
cool choice I don't want to ruin it for
if there are yeah when do the remasters
out this week if you haven't played it
go play it I think it's well worth it
right it does it gets Peru some as you
can see right here oh my god yeah right
away when you first get the skyhook and
you jam into the guy's neck oh yeah and
it just starts spinning and ride right
right right right jugular uh yeah no
these I actually the one complaint I
have about like pacing wise or you know
actual gameplay I felt too overpowered
toward the end maybe I was just playing
in Normal difficulty but by the time you
have all the different they're not
plasmids I forget what they're called in
this time right right change the name
yeah and by the time you have like I
know Mary just the other day when she
was here it was saying she just spammed
murder of crows that one ran she crows
of people I like the there's like an
earthquake one I think I don't know but
then yeah I mean I understand that and
yeah you could definitely feel that way
I'm that's understandable but I mean if
I'm doing crows all day I'm gonna get
bored right England you gotta change it
up sure the thing that actually in that
game i remember getting tired of was the
element of you taking down those giant
blimps yeah was that like toward the i
think that was a big fight toward the
engine ariel it's like it was just
really repetitive and i felt like it was
kind of half-assed but yeah in general
that was a very unique game compared
that franchise i respect them for
changing it up so heavily you know look
we do different the word it was weird
though cuz there was like a Coney Island
area it was kind of like I don't know
nineteen forties Brooklyn almost you
know the people lounging on the beach
and whatnot it dealt into some like
things in terms of like racism and then
also like there's like no Irish people
allowed in these bathrooms it just felt
very much like that era of America like
fear of immigrants and whatnot wasn't
there like some high society like
parties and yeah yeah trade and I
actually thought those were pretty cool
there's nice great kind of thing yeah
yeah I thought it mixed it up yeah I
don't know I liked it I thought the
world itself was super weird and in a
great way and I think yeah the logical
direction ago after rapture was up or
maybe I guess the
chuckle direction I don't know I'm not
an architect of sky cities but yeah I
don't know what do you guys do you have
any intention of return to those well
okay so if you didn't have like 90 other
games need to play and getting ready
playing on your games and traveling to
China and Japan like you are would you
return to the easy could or do you not
have any interest ya know I'd actually
like to I think it's been long enough
and I never gave Bioshock 2 a shot
so it'd be fun I'd like to yeah I might
yeah I you know if I were to pick one I
would probably start with one again I
mean of the three right it's like there
most notably different and and you know
is somewhat modernized I guess you could
say I start at one and say you feel you
know yeah I would still like to see do
two again to be honest like yeah kind of
forget those moments with big sister but
I remember like being frantic and like
running around and stuff and I yeah it's
member enjoying that element yeah
definitely I think I I kind of always
want to play all those they just feel
too great I love that vein of like the
Looking Glass Studios vein of game like
Deus Ex kind of like a Deus Ex System
Shock like now just honored has like
bioshock influence is kind of the
first-person shooter but very much more
measured pace to it and like almost
adventure aspects but yeah that's
Bioshock remastered collection tell us
in the comments below if you feel a plan
on playing either of them or I guess any
of the three in the near future tell us
what your favorite is tell us why you
don't like one or two or remastered and
yeah